pour beaucoup de gens, ce n'est pas significatif, mais
pour moi, ça l'est, mais cela signifie que vous étiez en
fait, vous pouviez voir le blanc des
yeux qu'ils tirent et on
vous tirera dessus un genre de chose que
je vois et je ne verrai jamais  oublie que j'ai été blessé
dans le même cas que le même automatique a
tué mon lieutenant qui était à environ dix
pieds à ma gauche la veille de cette
bataille j'ai perdu mon meilleur ami je n'en ai pas
parlé pendant 40 ans
[Musique]
le v-jour  nous étions à l'Elbe et
mon régiment a rencontré les Russes nous avions
beaucoup d'Allemands qui se rendaient à
nous parce qu'ils ne voulaient pas être
capturés par les troupes soviétiques
[Musique]
les Russes n'auraient pas pu gagner une guerre
sans nous et nous  Je n'aurais pas pu gagner la
guerre sans les Russes, nous avions un accord mutuel sur le fait
que nous devions le faire ensemble
[Musique]
J'espère voir le défilé, c'est important
pour moi car il reste beaucoup de gens
là-bas, probablement combien de personnes en
Union soviétique cela  Je suis parti pour me rappeler à quel
point c'était mauvais pour beaucoup de gens  les États-
Unis ne savent pas grand-chose de ce qui
s'est passé dans une guerre qui intéresse davantage les
Français, les Anglais, les Russes ou les
Soviétiques
parce que cela les a tous touchés,
ils ont perdu leurs grands-pères ou
leurs pères et j'ai parlé à des gens
Assurez-vous qu'ils se souviennent de ce qui
s'est passé et que cela ne se reproduise plus
moi
[Musique]